you mentioned your daughter she's two
and a half years old yes and what is she
into at that stage I I forget because I
have a fourteen-year-old daughter and I
have a 12 year old son and so I forgot I
forget what happens at what stage so two
and a half which is wide I don't think
this is a typical two and a half year
old thing but she wear so we're moving
right now and so there's a lot of foxes
and chaos and she was with me the other
day I was packing and I don't know where
she was like no ghosts I don't like that
ghost he's scary don't look at me ghost
and I'm like okay here we go
just try and get a rise out of me so I
said all right let's go to go to the
other room so she goes to the other room
and I'm I stayed behind and I just hear
in the other room
Oh uh-huh yes oh okay hey it's your body
your choice ghost okay ghost your body
your choice Amelie get her help that's
that's out of the Exorcist which is true
yes which is and she makes that note you
know it's so the Exorcist that the lead
character in the extra name is Reagan
yeah she does make those noises well I
don't know I'm I don't want to be a big
downer okay well there's a good chance
she's possessed by a very good tip
you